the natural beauty of North Wales
attracts hundreds of thousands of
tourists each year that and the
country's rich history they speak one of
the oldest languages in Europe here but
this message was written with those from
over the border in mind many of the
people here are key workers and want to
be left alone to do their essential jobs
I'm driving to meet one of them
[Applause]
please family farm is near call when as
a sheep farmer he's well practiced in
self-isolation every area of his
business is affected the price of lamb
he says has fallen off the cliff and
fire has stopped taking gas for his
holiday rental property right now we
have three or maybe four people asking
if he could come over Easter in the
beginning I was being quite nice to them
saying no they're all knocked down but
by the end there was telling them
they're being a bit idiots can't believe
that people still trying no really no no
it's absolutely because belief really
it's it's I don't know what planet they
are on with schools closed both his kids
come to work with him in the chicken
shed they bring new meaning to the term
egg hunt why
[Applause]
[Music]
only on the weekends but they're here
now because it's not okay
the soaring demand for eggs is another
notable quirk of the lockdown has gone
through fear and we can't produce enough
people staying home wanting to bake
it's been a a slight positive to this
nightmare that with him to get his
produce into the supermarkets clear
relies on delivery drivers then from car
more than share is one of them he's
parked up at the side of an industrial
estate this lorry cab belly two meters
wide has become his home he's moved in
for fear of bringing the coronavirus
back to his family
who what's in here then obviously bed
area and then yeah you got obviously
your bed there the middle locker there
is you microwave several storage lockers
fridge down there another locker there
and we have for five weeks the only
contact been has had with his girlfriend
and three young kids is a video call
each day and a socially distant drop off
of laundry son Jasper who was born ten
weeks premature is just three months old
there must be a feeling of intense
loneliness oh yeah when you're parked up
in the middle of nowhere eerily quiet
you're alone with your thoughts so your
mind just goes into overdrive you're
stuffing
homesick I think is the words you just
you just want to go home and then you
start oh I've missed this I've missed
that is there a limit to how many more
weeks months you would spend in there no
for me to keep my family state I'll go
years of after the Kevin Mauer viaducts
provides a grand welcome into Wrexham
where Kelly sell this so long two years
ago but she hadn't factored a global
pandemic into the business plan now
she's using her son as a her model for
online tutorials
yeah so everyone starting to feel bad
now the roots are coming my brows are
growing the message of me please help me
mm-hmm what can I do really think I can
do is short on videos like how how to do
it from home
similarly is life like for you at the
moment
hard hard it's a constant worry
did you know what you're getting in
terms of the government Grameen as it be
made clear enough to you yeah so one
meant to be open like the 10 the 10
grand grant it should be happening by
again we just waiting should that just
I'll keep you afloat depend on this
lasts I'm hoping you know it's not too
long and we're gonna be open there's
gonna be a massive chaos I'm you know
heading to the north coast of Wales and
the beauty of London no pier belies huge
economic and social strife I'm just
driving along the main seafront in
London no it's a stunning day usually it
would be filled with tourists but these
B&Bs and hotels are completely empty the
staff that usually work here are at home
now some of them furloughed some of them
are not being paid at all it's what
makes this place so vulnerable not to
the corona virus itself but to the
resultant lockdown experts predict
Llandudno will be among the ten town's
worse affected by the economic impact of
coronavirus and as ever it's the poorest
who will be hit hardest
I meet John sat outside a supermarket
his only home is a 10th in the hills
above the town hey John I notice you've
got the the rainbow on your your stick
yeah you know long as it's not
supportive you know
yeah has it been lonelier very yeah it's
a lonely likes to live on the street yet
almost anything yeah bull no this is
nothing cause they've got fear of people
anyway yeah but what's feeling me more
than anything you know she's you've also
do catch anything like that - truly
there's nothing but of those who do I
could nicely Michel there's nowhere I
could go no way I involve you okay
no cables well we were parked in the car
last night here
my husband Renzi and I used to be nice
I saw probably about try 14 people just
walked straight past you when the
husband proposes what change your big
it's heartbreaking isn't it particularly
times like this are you worried John
London knows expected to be one of the
worst hit places in terms of getting
back on its feet Lee seung-woo to death
a man would eat [ __ ] I'm on at Universal
code they didn't know where did no way I
didn t know where from survive I can
survive
John's desperation and uncertainty about
the future
he's mirrored across this country yeah
from those making adjustments to their
daily lives to all those trying to eke a
positive from their situation
life goes on here it feels empty Martha
Kellner Sky News Wales